[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
score je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle émission a
c'est parti pour le sommaire football ce
dimanche 3 juin du encore remporté la
finale de la coupe des yvelines contre
maurepas au terme d'un match à
rebondissements le score 3-2 le résumé
de la rencontre est à suivre dans
quelques instants
tennis cette année les yvelines sont
bien représentés à roland-garros au
niveau des joueurs des ramasseurs de
balle et des au sein même de la
fédération française de tennis
nous avons rencontré du côté de la porte
d'auteuil norbert rampeau l' ancien
président de la ligue des yvelines est
maintenant membre du conseil supérieur
du tennis multisports le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et l'île de
loisirs ont été une nouvelle fois le
théâtre du trophée des entreprises nous
course contre la montre destinée aux
acteurs économiques et administratives
du territoire
cette année plus de 600 participants se
sont affrontés reportage à suivre
on ouvre maintenant une large page
résultats
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
football ont joué ce week-end la finale
senior de la coupe des yvelines sur le
terrain de maisons laffitte lui en cours
a battu son voisin de maurepas dans un
derby un rebondissement score final 3-2
le résumé du match des images de camille
lambert en montage de jus la grande
ville puis en cours est devenu roi des
yvelines pourtant rien n'a été simple
contre maurepas ce dimanche 3 juin à
maisons laffitte et du en cours tentent
été mené au score 1 0 dès les premières
minutes de cette finale de la coupe des
hippies bonnet on a été surpris un petit
peu au début de match mais bon je
connais un peu mon groupe donc je savais
qu'on allait très bien réagir avec le
match allait devenir intéressant au fil
du temps donc aucune inquiétude quand on
a pris le but fallait juste qu'on
retrouve un peu notre jeu et qu'on
continue à jouer au ballon piqué au vif
du concours réagi pour marquer deux fois
plus sur coup avant la mi temps sur des
exploits individuels comme des matchs
retour en compétences pour finir sur un
sur des contres avec des pertes de balle
à ses hôtes sa part bientôt ça va vite
chez eux on connaît ils ont été hyper
réaliste des occasions de but en
première mi temps on rentre on rentre à
la mi temps on est mené 2 1
mais même on n'a peut-être pas fait
suffisamment prenants mi temps dans les
duels dans l'envié en seconde période
les guyot courtois continue à dominer
les débats se créent plusieurs occasions
et obtiennent un penalty non converties
par les joueurs finalement les grilles
près le large sur cette action
sans solution jusque là les murs
parisiens accélèrent et réduise le score
les verts toucheront même la barre dans
les dernières minutes mais le score
n'évoluera plus trop à deux victoires un
peu logique et pas à pas de surprise
pour moi
psychologiquement et physiquement je
pense qu'on est un peu mieux porte pas
sur cette deuxième partie de saison donc
pas surpris disons qu'on a bien préparé
notre match depuis un moment et puis on
les aurait été super motivés ou
d'absolument la gagner donc l'aiguillon
courtois terminent donc leur saison sur
un titre et une troisième place dans le
championnat de première division de
district les objectifs du club sont
atteints et gens peuvent maintenant
savourer on jouait également ce week-end
sur les terrains de baseball les cougars
de montigny le bretonneux ont réalisé la
bonne opération de cette 7e journée en
venant à bout du puck de paris ce
dimanche lésigny montain a longtemps
porté 17,1 dans la première rencontre et
6 1 dans la seconde partie
au classement les cougars pointe à la
troisième place avec 8 victoires en
douze rencontres disputées avec quatre
matches de retard sur le second du
classement sénart prochain match
dimanche prochain à partir de 11h à
domicile contre le muc barracuda à
baseball
elles aussi ont réussi une super saison
handball féminin pour clore sa première
année de création les féminines de
villepreux ont réalisé un sans faute
dans le championnat d'excellence
départementale les joueuses ont remporté
18 victoires sur la saison en 18 matches
disputés l'équipe termine également
meilleure attaque et meilleure défense
pour nous parler de ce carton plein à
nous recevons sur ce plateau
la présidente signé rodrigues
l'entraîneur jay à bord il ya la
capitaine charles and frank est la
gardienne fatou coulibaly tout on est
accompagné de céline et clémence neige
sur les ailes alors déjà première
question est ce que vous l'avez bien
fêter ce titre ceni on l'a plutôt bien
fait était effectivement jusqu'à 5
heures du matin avec une bonne partie de
l'équipe donc où est très très contente
de cette saison j'ai confirmé jeux
conférences confiant le soin
handballistiquement et après humainement
en dehors des terrains
c'est vrai que on a pris du plaisir tous
ensemble évoluant ensemble sur cette
saison j'arrive à m'en voulais expliquer
ce 18 sur 18
je pense que la motivation de tout
on s'est aussi entraîné pour réussir à
avoir ces résultats là
oui on n'a rien lâché en fait j'ai pas
tout la du même avis qu'eux même avis
oui on s'est bien battus jusqu'à la fin
et on a tous nos objectifs
alors quand tu comment on fait pour
garder quand même une équipe sous
pression quand on voit que le
championnat finalement et gagner on va
dire depuis longtemps comment on fait
pour les garder sous pression je crois
qu'il ya douze points d'avancé sur le
second mollo à l'afp j'appelle les ai
gardés sous pression en début de saison
des objectifs était simple c'était
vraiment de partir sur une bonne c'était
la création de partir vraiment sur une
saison de travail
je n'avais pas imposer forcément des
résultats
après s'est avéré que très vite tous
dans le championnat on s'est retrouvé en
tête
et plus le temps avance et et puis on
restait on voyait qu'on était les autres
équipes
loin derrière donc au bout d'un moment
c'est vrai que j'ai décidé de les
pousser à garder sa place là et avoir la
possibilité reste invaincu s'était du
coup un deuxième deuxième voire
troisième objectif pour les pois l'égard
des intéressés et motivés et pas
relâcher la marche des efforts ça marche
et ça a marché
photo le coach n'était pas trop dur avec
vous quand même cette saison
non ça va on peut souhaiter une reprise
j'avais arrêté l'homme depuis des années
ça franchement j'ai été coincé à rennes
vous confirmez je confirme aussi ça fait
quatre ans que j'avais pas fait de
rendre
et franchement tout s'est bien passé n'a
pas été dur il nous a supportés aussi
parce que des filles c'est quand même
compliqué à gérer donc très bien signer
si je comprends bien il ya des filles
qui ont intégré l'équipe ne jouait plus
au handball depuis quelques saisons
est-ce que c'est difficile de les
remettre en marche
en fait elles ont enfin elles se sont
très vite senti à l'aise en même temps
ça faisait un petit moment pour tous gpt
que cette équipe
effectivement c'était arrêté donc du
coup là on repartait vraiment sur la
création
en fait on s'est pas posé de questions
quoi ça s'est fait naturellement
et puis malgré qu'on est con et été
affaiblie par par des blessures au long
de la tout au long de la saison bat on
s'est serré les coudes et puis et puis
voilà il peut être question à se poser
ça s'est fait assez naturellement
alors c'est vous qui avez eu l'idée de
créer cette section est ce que
finalement vous voilà enfin finalement
on vous le regrettez rien je supporte
pas non non je ne regrette pas au
contraire je suis je suis très fier j'ai
l'impression que que je crée mon club la
henan enfin hier et au final ça fait
déjà apprécier un an que je suis un que
je suis nu et que voilà on a fait un
beau parcours on aime on est championne
dès notre première année on a on a des
filles qui sont intéressés pour nous
rejoindre
on a des filles qui sont venus dès cette
saison donc maintenant je suis très très
fier et puis c'est surtout grâce aux
filles qui ont intégré l'équipe funky
qui m'ont bien aidé jay est ce que vous
avez construit une équipe pour gagner en
construisant cette équipe l'été dernier
pour gagner oui et non après je
construis une équipe pour avoir des
résultats sur un certain moment je
compétiteurs et j'aime pas la chaîne
fera perdre
c'est vrai que l'objectif puisse ou
moins long terme c'est d'accéder au
niveau régional donc puis quelque part
je les j'essaie de les formater pour
pour la victoire mais c'est voilà on a
fait on a fait une petite partie à un
petit bout de chemin et voilà il reste
encore quand même beaucoup de travail
l'année prochaine on sera dans un
championnat qui sera autrement plus fort
avec des équipes qui vont peser plus de
difficultés il faudra que les filles
soient plus assidus plus exigeante avec
elle-même et même moi je vais aussi
durcir le ton forcément des
entraînements je lui ai peut-être plus
exigeants et moins de karni si sûr sur
certaines choses que ce soit aux
entraînements aux matches
charlène vous continuez dans l'équipe
l'année prochaine peut-être en fin de
saison je me suis fait les croisés à
quatre à quatre matches de la fin donc
opération et rééducation avant mais
sinon franchement oui bonjour j'ai dit
oui à tout il existerait ou cindy est ce
qu'il faudra recruter au mercato
forcément le niveau a monté ce qu'il
faut recruter de nouvelles joueuses pour
apporter étoffer encore plus ce gros bas
on a on a notre page facebook
effectivement où on a posté déjà un
message pour pour recruter des joueuses
sur la saison prochaine effectivement on
a eu pas mal quand même quatre blessés
sur la fin de la saison ce qui réduit
pas mal l'effectif en plus de celles
qu'ils arrêtent pour x ou y raison
donc du coup on a déjà posté un message
et tous nos entraînements de joints sont
ouverts à celles qui veulent essayer ou
celles qui veulent éventuellement nous
rejoindre l'année prochaine sans aucun
souci mais l'auteur pour le faire ce
sera des joueuses qui ne sont juste pas
débutante après on n'a pas vraiment de
préférence sur la base arias et où on a
le moins de d'effectifs mais
mais voilà la seule la seule réelle
exigence et des joueuses non débutante
merci à vous mais passé sur ce plateau
on continuera à suivre avec attention
vos résultats la saison prochaine et bon
courage pour le mercato qui s'annonce
agitée
si nous allons maintenant passer à
parler tennis et plus particulièrement
du tournoi de roland garros qui se
clôturera ce dimanche 10 juin à paris et
par les finales hommes cette année à les
yvelines sont bien représentés au niveau
des joueurs des ramasseurs de balle et
au sein même de la fédération française
de tennis nous avons rencontré norbert
rampeau là à côté du court philippe
chatrier
nous sommes porte d'auteuil à mes côtés
norbert ans paula qui a été pendant 28
ans le président de la ligue des
yvelines et qui est maintenant à la
fédération française de tennis alors
norbert en point là qu'est ce que vous
faites à la fédération française bien ce
que je fais je vais exercer les
fonctions de président du conseil
supérieur du tennis qui équivaut aussi
volé si on compare sa une société
conseil de surveillance donc c'est à la
fois l'évaluation les propositions et
voir le contrôle de la gestion de la
fédération française de tennis et du
coup vous êtes ici à roland garros
pendant la quinzaine pourquoi est ce que
vous allez faire
ben parce que je suis membre élu et je
bénéficie effectivement des ouvertures
de roland garros et vous portez un petit
peu la voix des yvelines ici non plus du
tout il ya un collège yvelines c'est
plus une digue ma danse et un comité
départemental et son président est là
aujourd'hui donc je suis hors ligue des
yvelines mais je suis bien entendu de
tout coeur avec les yvelines alors
j'imagine que vous continuez à suivre un
petit peu l'actualité quand même du
tennis yves binois il ya 2 français 2
heavy noah qui sont ici à roland garros
cette année
est ce que vous les connaissez bien sûr
je déconnais d'autant plus qu'ils ont
été entraînés à la ligue à 100% dans
l'eure
cursus ils ont participé ils ont été
champions de france unss
ils sont en université aux états unis
des deux et sont venus ici avec des wild
card pour participer aux internationaux
france en double il s'agit de florian la
cat et de arthur et niedernai tous deux
donc je croisais surface il joue pas
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je veux demain
demain voilà donc et j'irai les voir
vous les supporter bien sûr bien sûr que
ça vous fait vous de vous de voir des
yvelinois ici à roland garros ça n'était
pas arrivé depuis michael llodra qui
était de plaisir mais qu'at elle lodra
il ya eu également hicham arazi qui a
été formé aussi au pôle espoir de la
ligue des yvelines en son temps une
autre joueur bien entendu de voir des
unions à tous les ans c'est pas
forcément courant
qu'est ce que ça vous fait ce qu'il en
faut plus ah bah il en faut toujours
plus c'est évident mais c'est contré
concurrentiel
par ailleurs je dirais que ne vienne à
roland-garros la ligue
à l'époque les yvelines comité
départemental aujourd'hui figure parmi
des ce qui concerne les comités au
travers des 17 des 18 régions
métropolitaines
et d'outre-mer donc des places sont
chères et il faut être vraiment de bon
niveau pour être mais ça arrivera je ne
suis pas inquiet je pense que nous
aurons des éléments de qualité de valeur
qui seront portés des couleurs des
yvelines 2 illinois qui sont sur les
courts ya également lundi vinoy dans les
ramasseurs de balles est ce que vous les
connaissez ce que voulait supporte
également non on ne connaît pas parce
que c'est non pas que ce soit donnée
mais ils sont tellement je crois que ça
doit regrouper plus de 4000 jeunes qui
souhaiteraient être à roland garros pour
être ramasseur de balle et puis une
petite sélection qui s'opère et et que
malheureusement dans certains cas il n'y
a pas beaucoup de vins toutes les
régions ensemble principes eux
représentés d'île de france doit l'être
sûrement et puis voilà c'est comme ça
est ce que c'est un plus également pour
ces petits jeunes de de côtoyer leurs
stars de pouvoir leur parler
ah c'est évident que ça leur laisse des
souvenirs impérissables
ils sont fiers contents ils ont approché
comme vous l'avez dit des joueurs de
grande réputation et voir échanger des
fois avec eux c'est formidable c'est
incroyable pour eux c'est à l'envi aussi
peut être pour ces jeunes de continuer
ça peut leur donner envie de continuer
dans le tennis de s'accrocher parce que
c'est pas forcément facile non c'est
certain mais cependant se sont tous deux
joueurs de clubs qui sont sélectionnés
donc on ne peut leur souhaiter que de
progresser
et pourquoi pas dans un temps à veut
dire d'être ici en tant que joueur et
prôner effectivement leurs compétences
leur valeur tennistique ici à roland
garros merci beaucoup norbert ans paula
je vous laisse je crois que vous allez
voir rafael nadal jouait sur le court
philippe chatrier
merci beaucoup le plateau a été
enregistrée la veille du match de nos
deux yvelinois malgré une belle
résistance dans le deuxième set les deux
sportifs du département qui bénéficiait
d'une wild card florian la cat et arthur
rinat mèche se sont finalement inclinés
à mercredi dernier dès ce premier tour
contre la paire australo georgienne john
millman nichols basile à julie le score
6-3 3-6 7-5 ils retenteront de revenir
l'année prochaine du côté de la porte
d'auteuil du tennis mais cette fois-ci
de table tout au long du week-end avides
de gain en poids organise
le tournoi de la balle tu dors plus de
quatre cents pongistes se sont affrontés
sur 32 table au gymnase des droits de
l'homme
parmi eux neuf joueurs en situation de
handicap une première pour le tournoi
tiac été créé qui a créé une nouvelle
session pour qu'il puisse participer
affronter des valides
on écoute la présidente du comité de
tennis de table des yvelines au micro de
camille lambert
on a créé un tableau fauteuil ce qu'on
appelle un tableau assise et un tableau
de guy on a pas l'habitude de les voir
comme sartre dans une épreuve
départementale donc c'est ça qui
s'apprend s'est montré un petit peu à
tout le monde ce qu'ils sont capables de
faire
et puis de voir que finalement c'est pas
si facile de jouer contre eux parce que
ils ont aidé d'autres méthodes de jeu et
ils savent aussi embêtée leurs
adversaires multisports à présent c'est
devenu une tradition le trophée des
entreprises s'est déroulée jeudi 31 mai
entre le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et l'île de
loisirs une course contre la montre
destinée aux acteurs économiques et
administratives du territoire
plus de 600 participants ont donc
participer à cette 11e édition un
reportage de notre trio nicolas landry
camille lambert et grégory canal et de
la course à pied du golf du radeau ou
encore du vtt six épreuves pour ce
onzième trophée des entreprises sur un
parcours de plus de 7 km au coeur de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines un défi éprouvant à cette année
par rapport à mai si tu sais je pense
qu'à la fin il fallait inverser en
courant c'était un peu casse-gueule
france le radeau particulièrement cette
année en fait c'était
et le plus physique de toutes les
épreuves à ce que le racé de la course
encore pourquoi des grands groupes des
pme ou les services de communes du
territoire de nombreuses équipes venues
avec leurs supporters pour porter les
valeurs du sport et de l'entreprise les
valeurs du sport c'est bien sûr être le
meilleur mais en même temps il ya
beaucoup de sport d'équipé où là il faut
pas être seulement le meilleur il faut
être celui qui apporte le plus de valeur
ajoutée au groupe est en fait on
retrouve cette logique aujourd'hui
dedans donc elle est dans l'entreprise
à quelques mois de la ryder cup cette
édition du trophée des entreprises
avaient enfilé les couleurs de la
compétition mondiale de golf on ouvre
une page golf à présent pour développer
la pratique de la discipline vers le
grand public la fédération française a
signé plusieurs partenariats avec les
des golfs en france avec l'objectif
d'augmenter le nombre de licenciés un
chiffre qui serait aujourd'hui de 410
mille il ya quelques semaines au golf
boulugo indh a présenté à envoyer ma
maison son nouveau concept du sport pour
tous au programme des mini golf ludique
des practice dernière génération et des
parcours du combattant pour améliorer sa
technique
un concept qui devrait être déployé sur
le golf de saint quentin en yvelines sur
l'île de loisirs on écoute le président
de blue green le principe de toutes nos
installations est double il est d'abord
pour les golfeurs de leur permettre de
de d'avoir des installations de
meilleure qualité sur lesquels ils
peuvent s'entraîner mais également à des
non golfeurs de venir passer un moment
qui leur donnera des sensations
forcément agréable de toucher de balle
de distance et sans doute padres qu'il
ne soupçonne pas
parce qu'on considère aussi le golf et
c'est une autre des idées reçues comme
un sport difficile
nous on veut le rendre ludique d'abord
et donner envie aux gens d'avoir à le
pratiquer on continue à parler de golf a
exactement cent quinze jours de la ryder
cup qui se déroulera sur le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines tv
66 vous propose de découvrir chaque
lundi de l'histoire de la compétition
aujourd'hui christophe muniesa le dtn de
la fédération française de golf nous
livre l'un de ses meilleurs souvenirs
regardez je me souviens de l'édition de
la ryder cup de 2002 édition qui s'est
jouée sur le parcours du belfry en
angleterre c'est une édition qui avait
une saveur un peu particulière car c'est
la première épreuve de ryder cup qui
s'est joué après les événements
de 2001 on s'en souvient la ryder cup de
2001 était programmé là quelques jours
après la tragédie du 11 septembre et
les videmment suite à cette tragédie les
équipes américaines et européennes ont
fait le choix ont pris la décision de
reporter le match
il n'y a donc pas eu de ryder cup en
2001 et l'épreuve a été reportée en 2002
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
avec la ryder cup qui se doit qui se
jouera en 2018 en france
désormais les éditions de ryder cup se
joue les années paires et plus les
années impaires
alors que la première édition de la
ryder cup c'est joe une année impaire en
donc cette cette épreuve avait là aussi
une dimension un petit peu historique
l'équipe américaine était ultra forte
vous me direz comme à chaque fois mais
là c'était vraiment impressionnant
notamment avec tiger woods qui était au
top de sa forme ou phil mikelson qui lui
aussi faisait figure de favori et
l'équipe européenne emmenée par sam
torrance avait en face d'elle un gros
morceau à avaler
contre cette équipe américaine et c'est
comme bien souvent sur le parcours du
belfry que de nombreux matchs se sont
dénoués sur le trou ultime le trou
numéro 18
il ya notamment eu une sortie de bunker
rentrée de paul azinger le joueur
américain pour égaliser 1 point
et
de la même manière un match homérique de
collines montgomery qui était allé
chercher un point et alors que les
européens étaient au coude à coude avec
les américains dans les simples ils ont
dans la deuxième partie dans le dimanche
après midi et réussi à prendre
l'avantagé et je me souviens
parfaitement du point du demi point qui
a été ramené par paul mcginley à
l'époque il était joueur de ryder cup
avant d'en être le capitaine quelques
années plus tard ça s'est passé sur le
green du 18 il a rentré un pote de six
mètres pour s'imposer pour marquer ce
point de la victoire et l'équipe
européenne a envahi le green aux côtés
de l'équipe américaine
c'était une victoire non pas inespéré
pour l'équipe européenne mais en tout
cas c'était véritablement une victoire
avec panache qui s'est inscrit dans
cette période qui a marqué un petit peu
la suprématie de l'équipe européenne
contre l'équipe américaine
[Musique]
on poursuit ce magazine par du cyclisme
ce samedi 9 juin se déroulera la 15e
édition de la monty cyclo au départ du
centre sportif pierre de coubertin à
montigny le bretonneux pour nous parler
de ce rallye cyclotouriste nous recevons
sont en plateau alain léveillé
vice-président du vcmb cyclo le
responsable de l'organisation
françois-xavier chamois régis l'année
des laïcs le président bonsoir messieurs
alors si vous avez hâte à la réveiller
que tout commence bien sûr c'était une
grosse organisation qu'on organise donc
c'est la quinzième édition et qui
représente 1 à l'investissement
logistique important avec près de 50
bénévoles ont été combien de temps à
préparer l'événement dont quatre au
moins trois mois de préparation
donc comme on accueille 500 participants
comme l'année dernière donc ça nécessite
toute une logistique pour assurer les
ravitaillements alors pour les personnes
qui ne connaissent pas du tout la monde
ici l'eau qu'est ce que c'est
concrètement la montée c'est que c'est
une randonnée à vélo qui s'adresse aussi
bien aux licenciés de la fédération
française de cyclotourisme cyclisme mais
aussi aux non ils sont six pour
justement permettre à tout le monde y
trouvait son compte on propose trois
parcours un parcours de 100 km un autre
deux cent cinquante et un troisième de
200 pourquoi justement proposé à
plusieurs parcours ben pour satisfaire
déjà les goûts tous là les 2 200 ça
s'adresse plutôt aux habitués un ceux
qui ont qui sortent régulièrement
donc là on leur propose de venir tôt de
partir entre 6h et 7h30 du matin
et puis ils ont toute la journée pour
faire le 200 km le 150cc là encore pour
des gens entraînés assez déjanté des
cyclotouristes qui sortent tous les
dimanches moyens qui font moins la
sortie dominicale est donc là ils
partiront entre 7h30 et 8h30
et puis pour terminer pour ceux qui
veulent goûter un petit peu à des
sorties un début de longues distances et
à dire 100 km c'est comme aux chiffres
eh bien on leur propose de devenir de
partir entre 7h et 9h et puis ils ont
toute la journée pour le faire et s'ils
roulent régulièrement 40 50 km
liseron plaisir d'avoir fait cette
sortie avec jean et delek vous êtes
d'accord il frappe à une jambe
pour participer il faut un petit peu
d'entraînement des exactement mais on
n'a pas besoin d'être hyper sportifs
comme le disait françois effectivement
les pratiquants du triathlon par exemple
sont souvent très présent sur le 200 et
on a notre groupe détente qui lui s'est
préparé pour le 100 km donc depuis six
mois il roulait le rouler ils vont
centrale il s'entraîne y voilà alors
c'est un événement qui permet d'avoir
une visibilité pour votre club
est-ce que ça débouche forcément sur de
nouveaux licenciés au niveau de la
lentille cyclo pas obligatoirement mais
on a aussi fait la semaine dernière
ce week-end une
une journée portes ouvertes féminine
qu'il a à d va déboucher sur de
nouvelles féminine au club il faut
savoir continue on est déjà le plus gros
club d'île de france et en féminines on
espère augmenter de 20% suite être notre
journée portes ouvertes et des prix
seront quand même remis à la fin de la
compétition
alors oui nous il ya des lots des
récompenses pour les participants mais
comme il n'y a pas de classement c'est
un petit peu une question aux questions
d'âge et puis un petit tirage le
méritant c'est aux plus méritants et
c'est parce que c'est une épreuve qui
n'est pas chronométrés dont il n'y a pas
de classement donc c'est la
caractéristique puisque cerveau c'est
avant tout du vélo de loisir et il n'y a
pas de moyenne à respecter n'est quoi
que ce soit dernière question vous avez
15 secondes est ce qu'on peut encore
s'inscrire
oui on peut s'inscrire soit sur le site
internet haute approuvé ce bébé vcmb sur
google ait pu vous tomberez sous le site
internet du club et on peut s'inscrire
là dessus soit tout simplement venir le
jour j merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois le passé sur ce plateau je
rappelle la date aux téléspectateurs la
compétition sera organisée ce samedi à 9
juin à partir de 6 heures du matin au
départ du complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin à montigny le bretonneux
renferme ce magazine par deux
rendez-vous une compétition de tir à
l'arc sera programmée ce samedi les
archers de lui en co organisent leur
traditionnel tir du roy au gymnase des
droits de l'homme de 10h à 20h
plus de 300 compétiteurs sont attendus
pendant l'événement si vous voulez
assister à ce rendez-vous l'entrée est
libre
à elancourt ce samedi 9 juin une
trentaine d'associations proposeront des
démonstrations des initiations sportives
à l'espace sportif pierre de coubertin
de 14h à 18h au programme découverte des
sports collectifs comme le rugby le
football le handball et le basket ball
initiation aux sports de combat et aux
arts martiaux à l'athlétisme or la
rocqué notamment un village ryder cup
consacre au golf sorel également
installés pour tester la petite balle
blanche
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tb
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]